I bombed these are T of the funniest
stories told by comedians about bombing
on stage I'm obviously not a [__]
bomb expert but I talked to one and
he man goes hey dude hey bro you come up
and do you know come to La bro so I went
up there on a Saturday night and mity
saw me there and I was hanging out with
Carlos in the main room green room and
Carlos goes hey mity put him
up right you're a new comic I'm new and
and MIT goes yeah you go up and Joe
roken says Joe Rogan's there MIT he's
from [__] San Diego he's not funny or
something like that he's not [__]
funny right yeah he'll be fine that's
what she said I went up there not only
did I not hear any laughs I hear Rogan
in the back going I [__] told you
he's not funny he's not [__] funny
mity he's from La Hoya right and I
remember eating it so bad you can feel
it oh oh my God it it was also like one
of those sets where I went oh maybe it
I'm not going to make it oh you know
maybe yeah maybe it's just like I was a
local yeah San Diego what who am I
competing against you know but maybe in
the big leagues I just don't have it in
retrospect is because I just didn't
wasn't you weren't ready I wasn't ready
that's all you were good you just
weren't ready I wasn't even good I
wasn't even good it was just like I just
know wasn't ready can you give me one of
your jokes that bomb yeah oh yeah yeah I
used to do um I'm so lonely
right I'm so lonely when I used to when
I
masturbate I grab my own ass right and I
go and then I turn around I go do me do
me and I start squeezing my CH cheek and
then my opening act my opening line was
I used to make my hair really messy yeah
so it was out of control and I would go
I'm not really Asian I just woke
up oh my God hey do you remember uh
remember that time the Steinberg's they
booked us and we did that benefit for
Peter remember and you hosted and you
went up and bombed and then I went up
and I bombed it and no one was the only
two people listening was the two guys
from queery for For The Straight Guy
like they actually were respecting that
it was a show and everyone was talking
then Patrice went up and just when he
went up and he just started quietly
talking about how he ate a puppy for
breakfast was in New York we did yeah
and they kept they cut off his they cut
off the lady tell get stage he goes why
who are you he goes she goes I don't
want to put this together he goes I
don't give a [__] he just kept talking
kept just talking about cooking this
puppy slowly and then they cut off his
mic and then he went over to the piano
which he couldn't play and started
banging on the piano and he's looking
over us like smiling I just remember
thinking like why didn't I do that why
did I just stand there doing my act like
a [__] [__] cuz I remember I did
my first joke it didn't work and then
did my second joke that didn't work and
you know patrice's left he did
that a he just started laughing and I'm
we're just up there just bombing we all
bombed we all [__] bombed we all
bombed and then he went up and he talked
about eating a puppy for breakfast and
he he was like our hero and he wouldn't
get off the stage the lady literally had
to cut off the mic and she was like this
soccer mom like I'm running [__] I'm
[__] doing this you [__] nobody
gives a [__] about you with your your
weird hips you know he just like
whatever the [__] he was saying to her I
just remember in the end she finally
gained control of the microphone and
Patrice just he didn't get off the stage
had to end the show with he was up there
tickling the [__] ivories we've all
done those like corporate gigs too we
like to like be clean and you're like I
got this and then a minute in you're
like bombing you're like [__] it I'm
doing my I'm doing my titty [__] chunk
let's do this yeah I was titty [__]
out a football game I had that happen
the other night on state where I'm at
the Sellar and a woman I did a bit about
going down on a woman it wasn't even
like a dirty version it was like a
pretty clean version of that and she
stood up like this is [__] disgusting
I was like I didn't actually do it in
front of you it's a joke I'm not just
saying I ate a [__] and she she and her
husband get up and give me the finger
this the best part is the husband tries
to pull his pants down to Moon me as
they're getting kicked out I'm like you
call me you call my joke disgusting
you're trying to show me your old bare
ass they were like in their 60s what
yeah it was pretty gross just for doing
this bit they were yellow skinn uh I
mean like tan from the Sun not Asian I
don't mean like a that was you know what
I meant they they're ill they're like
ceros ding was with Chappelle all week
not big deal but then uh not big deal
just had to tell you guys where I was
whatever dude oh by the all right let me
tell you about that Dave Chappelle was
filming a new special but he filmed it
at where he filmed Killing Him Softly so
it was like it was pretty sick yeah and
then they were like Dave wants you to
open I was like yes I'll absolutely be
there and then I get there and I'm the
first opener which is fine yeah totally
fine obviously fine the other two was it
was lunell and earthquake obviously I'm
number one for sure I get in there but
because it's a taping they have to start
on time so they're like like all right
seven get the [__] out there dude I go
out to 30% full all black room with
lights on no one's in their seats people
are just the whole time people are just
walking in everyone's I [__] every
single show I [__] hate it like you
wouldn't believe and I just had to stand
there like hey what's up guys people
were
just I would make a joke and people
would for real be like
no oh no you know how ice is is cool
right like what and of course it was
this past week so I'm up there like I
support the terrorists honestly that's
what sucks like I'm not changing my [__]
dude you guys figure it out that was my
only saving moment was I would finish it
and be like I understand this isn't the
best week for this material that would
be a laugh that's pretty funny the only
laughs I got was making fun of my own
set people like yeah you do
suck I was like guys you don't know I'm
actually pretty good in the white
Community but this just popped into my
head I wasn't thinking about this today
but did wasn't there a story about you
performing at like Dao's birthday or
something oh my God I mean it's my it's
my my most uh beloved s story so it was
this thing where dairo his wife calls me
up she goes Dao Bob's having a 60th
birthday party you do a dairo impression
which I really didn't but I maybe I did
a half ass one but she goes could you
come down and just do the impression I
go I'll do better than that I'll do an
act and even she goes like this like uh
um all right I mean we just want the
impression I go I'll do trust me I'm you
know she's like all right so right away
so I write an act a 20 minute act it's
all on paper you can't memorize an act
in three days of 20 minutes specific to
one person I write it all out about
dairo but it's got It's it's when I look
back on it h i go show up there's Billy
Crystal Robin Williams whoopy Goldberg
there's Irwin Winkler there's big
producer of all the the movies there's
Chaz Pomer there's Christopher Walker
and all these guys are there you know
all these big names yeah is that a
restaurant or at a restaurant called lir
the fanciest restaurant in New York at
the time so once again now part one
mistake she told you do the impression
get out and I got to be a big shot but
in my mind I'm like you know what this
is my time I was doing great at stand up
I was feeling my oats I was like this is
going to finally put me with gesi dairo
and these guys are going to go this is
the this is the guy Missing Link for
later why don't we know about this guy
you know cuz I'm from New York I'm just
like in my mind in back of my mind was
my you know and then I go up there she
goes I'll introduce
you no don't introduce me don't
introduce me don't I got it well what am
I stupid yeah I mean of all and I go
I'll just go up so I have to interrupt
dinner they're eating I lay out my notes
I get the mic and Robin Williams who was
there goes to me yeah he goes suddenly
I'm eating and I look up and I see you
talking to a microphone I go what's
Colin Quinn doing he's a comedian and
he's wondering what's going on so I
start getting the cry I go hi how you
doing um I'm not really a friend of Jiro
again cr's like why would a non-friend
be here at his birthday yeah and I go
but I seen his movies and I make a few
roast jokes so I go hey how did you
prepare you always prepare for your
movies how' you prepare for whatever
movie it was by looking in front of the
mirror and apologizing to the audience
for wasting our money like who
and I go hey you gained weight for
Raging Bull and you put on some weight
for uh Untouchables and G I maybe you're
not a really Ana you're just a fat [__]
oh so crowd's turning on me so I'm
bombing like that was the my first page
was all roast jokes yeah sure I had four
pages so I do roast jokes so then the
crowd's Turning so then I go I start
freewheeling cuz I got Chris walking and
those guys were over there and I go hey
I just St playing because I'm I didn't
know they'd be there but I'm like get
off the Nero I go hey Javi Kel what are
you doing here shouldn't you make
yourself at home take your pants off CR
just look at me he's looking at me I go
Chris Walkin why you here you should be
doing a cameo in an unwatchable
independent movie CR just looking at
me so now I know I'm bombing with the
roast jokes so I go into you're like let
me switch it up yeah I try to switch it
up so I go to my next page me I'm
Shuffling papers oh no so that was such
good I'm telling you this crowd is dead
silent I interrupted a meal of laughs
and you know what I mean cuz they're
like the Kentucky thing they're at their
party too yeah it's their party yeah
yeah yeah I'm not even his friend they
don't know me so I start going into this
other uh this horrible story of my
friend
who I'm embarrassed even tell my friend
who he died but before but we he had
seen taxi driver and when we were
growing up and he started describing
taxi driver to me and how you know how
strange it was that he was mentioning
taxi driver but then at the end of go
and then he died and it was like this it
was terrible and then are you seeing Bob
just like what's that you see like Bob's
like Bob's like looking like he's like
he's going you know like keep going like
he's trying to support because you know
he's horrified people like muttering
like you know it's getting ugly you know
and then people like like a couple of
you know ladies yelling out and [__]
then I start doing especially during the
roast jokes you know then I start doing
this other thing I'm doing like scenes
from I can't even remember I'm thank God
I hunt those papers because if I did I'd
have to I'd have to perform it again you
have to you have but it was so bad and
it just ended so ugly and I left and my
suit was soaked with sweat yeah and I
walk outside and Robin Williams came out
and he goes kie because I knew him a
little bit and he goes oh he start left
he goes oh you I was like look I had
another gig that night it was kind of
rainy so I have this new Cashmere
sweater on a hanger and I go I don't and
then casby sweater flew off the hanger
and went in the gutter and a cab ran it
over in the rain and he just cried with
laughter he couldn't believe it I was
hosting and I bombed right out of the
gate and I bombed every time I went up
that night in front of her and her
friends and when they walked out they
couldn't even look me in the face her
friends that's how bad Boston Comedy
Club bomb in there was brutal like you
said Savage the date no it was done it
was done that happened to me it was
why I met a chick one time at what the
[__] some Festival she came up to me she
was into me and then I went up on stage
and bombed and I could not find her
after the
show the owner of the Mets hired you to
do a private show the owner of the Mets
and also Tommy Mata the big music
industry EXA Mariah car's ex-husband
okay is there is there it's at the scene
completely it's at this restaurant in
the city which was a beautiful
restaurant he's the owner of the Mets he
owns the New York metropolitan
millionaire the show billions was
created after his life based off his
life based off his life so how I got the
gig was his wife is PTO Rican Puerto
Puerto okay I do jokes about you know
Puerto Rican women in my life because I
have Puerto Rican children Puerto Rican
girlfriend your Puerto Rican friends
you're Puerto Rican well but it's really
well it's Cuban though aren't you Cuban
more Puerto Steve Cohen's wife Puerto
Rican and his children has Puerto Rican
children first of all Steve C has about
eight kids it's like he's Amish but a
couple of those children areer R from
from his current wife beautiful wife so
she allegedly liked my stand up cuz I do
all the stuff about Puerto Rican Steve
con has no idea who I am okay the
birthday party we were under the
impression was going to be a family
birthday party okay so they a family
birthday party so I'm going to go up do
comedy for the family the wife knows oh
hun this is my I I like this comic blah
blah blah blah you were bringing out
Puerto Rican content I was literally
like all I'm going to do is my Puerto
Rican jokes because that's what the you
got to make the wife happy wife happy
life sure she'll laugh at him whatever
Steve will say all right this kid's in
yeah okay get to the game
it's 10 guys upstairs at a private T
they rented out the entire restaurant
The Terrace the balcony of the
restaurant is in on Park Avenue New York
City traffic honking away 600 p.m. I
could hear the cars from downstairs to
win wrestling New York City day 10 guys
10 billionaires sitting at a table
getting served food martinis you know
penguin meat all the Exotic stuff they
have no idea a comedy show is going to
happen oh the worst no one ever tells
him a comic's coming one ever says the
comic's coming on that's nothing they
never they have no idea it's about to
happen it's a surprise for Steve okay
okay I get there I go to you know start
the show there's no microphone no
nothing the guy one of the friends who's
just like a fun guy like everybody was
fun one of the guys he doesn't know who
I am he goes are you the comic I go yeah
he goes what's your name I go Chris
stephr goes I'll never remember that so
I go great so he's going to introduce me
so Amilia me and Emil are like this
going to go B's with you yes he's giving
me martinis which I told you I never had
a martinis oh you're drinking martinis
before the show because I never got into
Martin and I said to I said I've never
drank a Martin before he said trust me
you're going to love it this is a drink
of an adult so I start drinking the
martinz I'm like you're right I I now
now I can't stop I put on four pounds I
don't even cuz I'm not factoring the
martinis into my fness I I don't see the
four I don't see them so I'm doing and
then and then somebody asked me what
kind of Martini was it I said I have no
idea it was dry wet neat dirty I don't
know they I that's all different things
but sure yeah I just got it it was great
so the guy the guy um I think his name
was Ted he goes yeah I'll never remember
your name I say yeah he goes yeah we
don't have a mic mhone I go don't tell
me I go I go okay I go well where's the
show he goes at the front I figure you
just stand in front of the table there's
no stage No Light No nothing it's 6:00
it's outside on a roof deck so you could
hear the New York City traffic the
waiters waiters don't even know there's
a comedy show there're serving dinner
and serving drinks I'm standing out at
they didn't get you a
mic they come the waiter says they tell
the staff hey can we get this guy mic
the owner comes up with the mic he goes
hey we have a mic but no PA system so I
said so what do you you mean so just
just for just for em motion yeah just
for physicality so it was like he was
like it's a mic but you know we don't
have we don't have time to to you know
Echo it through the PA system so we can
just give you a dead mic I said okay
I'll take it
you you took it you did stand up with a
dead mic a cordless
mic just for the for the cuz just for
the just because I was like I got the
muscle memory I got to have something
yeah
I'm mic I was what am I Madonna I got
fre I just got the earpiece yeah Janet
Jackson Rhythm Nation yeah what the
hell's going on so now I have a dead mic
for these how funny is that yeah it's
not Amplified whatsoever not what yeah
not whatsoever so I was getting you know
good money it's a corporate gig whatever
good money you know Steve's a
billionaire very generous guy great guy
uh uh Ted brings me up I I forgot to say
because he said I'll never remember that
Ted goes he goes hey he goes Steve we
got surpris me we got a comic he goes
you guys probably don't know who he is
he goes I forgot his name but I heard
he's funny he goes all right kid come on
so
I swear to God I'm walking out with the
dead mic I say I say Ted what an
introduction I really appreciate it I
said you really know how to make a girl
feel welcome thinking I let get a little
laugh that didn't get a laugh Steve
Cohen turns to me and goes literally I'm
talking about Sal on stage for 8 seconds
he goes how long did they tell you to do
I said 45 minutes he goes no chance
you're making 45 minutes he goes I'll
double whatever they're paying you right
now to do 10
minutes I swear to God oh my God like
that's if he did he mean it cuz that's
an amazing deal you take that deal I
said to him I said I said what is this
Christmas I said you're going to give me
twice the Mone to do 10 minutes he said
absolutely he goes we want to get back
to the dinner I swear to God it was
happy but also I'm like wow I'm going to
bomb in that moment I felt a bead of
sweat traveling down my spine vertebrae
by vertebrae until it it puddled onto
the top of my ass crack just I mean a
full swe bang yes so then I start doing
show first joke come out of the gate
come out of the gate I say because it's
a Bobby Bonia joke Bobby Bonia has been
being paid by you have a Bobby Bonia
joke I don't have a Bobby Bon joke I
know he's he's wasting their whole
entire budget right their um yes yeah
yeah yeah yes so I he was they're still
paying that he's still getting paid he
hasn't been on the meds for 25 years I'm
like I'm like oh Steve I just want to
make sure I get the money I said I don't
want a Bobby Bon De I want it all up
front they had to kill nothing zero
they're like no they're like just
looking at me okay then I say who who do
we got here I said who do we got here
you know whatever and then Steve goes oh
this is uh this is Tommy mola and I said
oh I loved your cell phones as a kid he
goes That's
Motorola so then then ready then I try
another joke I forgot what I say bombs
the only laugh I get of the night
exploded with laughter this is about 7
minutes into the set but oh by the way I
I'm literally in the middle of a bit I'm
in the middle of a bit one of the bits
that cuz I was just doing old school
ones like you know the joke I in like oh
three years one [__] when I'm like
I'm dating this girl it's what I used to
close on Christopher Christopher it's
like it's like a bit that I haven't done
because I'm like you know trying to work
on the new stuff but I'm like I have no
choice to get out you're doing blow job
material at Steve Cohen's birthday cuz
it's 10 guys because in my opinion it's
for 10 guys for 10 billionaires in their
50s and 60s they either want to they
either want to have Jerry Seinfeld come
out or hookers one or the other it's
like it's not a 36y old guy that nobody
knows doing comedy the only person who
knew who I was there was Steve Cohen's
son who's also half Puerto Rican he came
up to me after the set he goes that was
brutal he goes but I'm a big
fan yeah and then he said to me he said
to me I'll d m you tomorrow I'll DM you
tomorrow you come sit in the suite with
me and my dad in the Mets game he'll
love you if the guys areen here I that
was that gig was 10 days ago no DM I've
been checking like like a supermodel
told me she was refreshes from Steve con
son but great kid shout out Steve con
son great Steve Cohen son if you're if
you're watching and we know you are hit
him with the DM get him up in that shout
out sweets so it became a thing where
Steve Cohen started asking me questions
it became a podcast with me and Steve
Cohen Steve was like where you from told
them where I'm from try to do doing Crow
work on you Steve was literally doing
Crow nobody's laughing one one guy one
guy one guy said he goes he goes oh he
goes um he goes uh he goes oh yeah our
friend bill down there he he lost 50 lbs
uh from from his recent divorce he goes
you think but but what do you think he
really lost to 50 PBS from I was like I
don't know cancer and he was like yeah
how'd you know and I was like oh my God
I swear to God I swear to God and I was
like I was like oh I'm I'm I'm so sorry
I'm like legitimately like you know so
sorry I and then and then and then Steve
goes I'm just with you place explodes
I'm like oh my God so he gets the
biggest laugh no the biggest laugh of
the night is what I got off on which was
crowd work with matah I didn't say
anything but Steve said that's enough I
go to Tommy mola I say oh you're Mariah
car's ex uh ex-husband I said you know
what I used to love Mariah Cary as a kid
he goes I guess you also loved [__] as a
kid explodes explodes Steve Cod almost
falls out of his seat I say thank you
good night I appreciate it you've all
been great they start clapping it up
they G gives me twice as much of the
money I sent an email with the alilio to
the to the to the guy who put it all
together the next morning so we're so
sorry that was an impossible situation
you have to understand Chris is
excellent at these gigs or you know he's
he this is his words not mine he's
saiding he is our guy for the corporate
gigs cuz he can stick and move and do
the crowd work but it was impossible the
waiter and waight step they were bumping
into him nobody was listening wasn't the
right move they right back mik they
right they right back we don't know what
you're talking about Steve loved him are
you serious I swear to God they go Steve
loved him wow they we'll be hearing from
us again we like to book him on more
parties we loved them I was like what
when someone's at a table and they're
like yeah we should I mean the guacamole
Dip's good you're like what so I did one
of those I'm like what was that he's
like ah yeah he says something and then
I say something Snappy back to him I'm
like you know I don't know why don't you
there's something about like a a dog
group there or something and I was like
well why don't you put your head in a
bowl like a [__] Dogwood or something
but you didn't know there was a dog
group there or you did no I I I knew
that I knew there was something dog
related I remember it was like a dog
line and then I remember when I said
that and as opposed to most times you
say something like that the person you
say it to might be like hey I remember
like six people were like what was that
like all at once yeah and I was like you
hurt like oh that's a lot of people
reacting to that I tried to like go on
and people were like you can't say that
to him like like right away and then it
just it starts to build it's like when
something just spreads realize in
retrospect is that most comedy shows you
know there's tables there's groups of
two four you know maybe five six people
go together but usually a bunch of that
couples and groups right friends so this
is uh late November holiday parties are
big and comedy clubs during this time so
there's two groups there having holiday
celebrations for like their work and but
they don't know each other these two
groups these two group but one is a
group of 60 oh [__] and one is a group
of 80 damn okay and one of those two
groups is also doing a fundraiser as
part of like part of the show they're
going to do like some type of giveaway
and like some type of uh what's it
called like a bidding you know like
auction to raise and that's that's the
dog thing as it's starting to go like as
you as you're like this this is starting
to turn starting to go south it's like
the group that wasn't related to the
first guy starts to go like what's going
on like and then they start to get
louder [__] told him put his
head the dog B
cross and here's the thing when that's
in the
air you're like you're trying to I go
you can't knock that down like no I'm
like let's put this back on the tracks
and just go to material and at the time
I'm like that's that's the thing to do
and dude like you can't like it's it's
uh
I start doing like a bit it just feels
disingenuous you're like people here are
upset they're starting to say [__] and
then just like that out of nowhere so
the the the feature Act was black and
the F this first person goes bring back
the black
[Music]
guy the black guy yeah and then other
people are like that's a good idea bring
them back and they start like bring them
back and then they're like you [__]
suck and then they're just going
boo like
that like that and I mean a parade of
boots and what are you doing are you
just standing up there looking you can't
like it's so loud yeah you're not
getting out of that no no no so then at
one point I feel like it's so
ridiculous I just find a how long how
long is this going on you're 10 minutes
in how long is this like 15 minutes of
this [__] I mean it ends up I end up
being on stage for about 33
minutes and at one point I pick a light
like a light from the you know in the in
the room that's supposed to be a stage
light and I just stare at it and I start
just telling jokes to the light you know
I'm just like hey man and I just run
material at the light cuz I know like
they're all they don't care and they
just getting louder and louder it's so
loud in there it's like they're louder
than the speakers MH and they're having
like full conversations and like cuz
they're like [__] this guy you know and
the uh the manager of the club comes on
stage at like 28 minutes and he goes are
you okay and I go yeah and he's like are
you sure I go yeah he goes all right he
leaves I keep like again just like I'm
talking to the ceiling it's it's so loud
I can't I mean it's like it's not like
if you're listening you're like so
you're just like acting weird like no
it's so loud in there it doesn't matter
what I'm doing like I was thinking of
just like pulling up recipes and reading
those right and uh at one point I see
the manager walk up again with a
woman and I'm like she comes on and
she's like Shell Shocked she's a little
older and she's like I can I can I have
the microphone for a second and I'm like
um okay so I give her the mic and she's
like we came here
tonight trembling to raise money for
these dogs and this man deserves an
opportunity to [__] you [__] that's
exactly what happened of s it is they
shut up mom mentality bring the black
guy back that's 100% I'm at the comedy
club and she's like can we please just
give him an opportunity and they're like
no I know for a fact this BL like you
can tell when it's a blow audience you
can just feel it I'm hosting and I'm
like blow would [__] Crush he would
level the room and so I have to like
I was like I need to like really tell
them like make sure they know like three
times I was like guys again I told them
when he comes up here do not react at
all this is a good friend of mine but
just do not laugh at anything he says
don't Boo don't Heckle just stay
silent dud I feel bad I'm in hle I feel
bad about this I owe you an apology I'm
just thinking about this this the thing
I've ever done and let me say this too
when I was waiting the wings and just to
hype this up before we see it like you
said it before but I was not pass to his
Club so for a Booker to call me in this
is a big deal also the booker is in the
room so I can't even go off script to be
like what the [__] is wrong also true I
can't do crowd work I can't do anything
I wanted he wanted to see a set so I'm
not going off script and another thing
too is I walk in I ask Benji who's the
book at the time I go how are they he
goes unbelievable and
then and what's insane too is I poke my
head in and AA is murdering so I'm like
oh thank God man for me back then if I'm
murdering back then if I'm murdering he
got yeah yeah yeah so I'm like I'm like
oh this is this is great and and I just
came from uh uh another cond club where
I did I Mur I was like I was feeling so
good I was like oh running light them
bring me up going in one thing I will
say I did I was like you have to pass
him after this for real you canot pass
him after this so I was looking out for
you a little bit but I'm still a
terrible person and I apologize I was a
much angrier guy because I was poor and
unfunny but this is the this is the
prank I am so [__]
nervous good you find I've had it dude I
watch it sometimes when I
[Laughter]
feel they're pulling the [__] up on
quick time this is an old ass video bro
wow this is an old clip [__] what's up
[__] Good Start um everyone's
good everyone's feeling good
cool [__] I'm feeling good man happy
Father's Day and [__] um I I was hanging
out with my little nephew today he's
super cute years old and he Uncle
Michael I can't watch sound just like
elb it's cutest thing ever he was like
tle be there and I was like I'm not that
type of Uncle not fight recently and I
live in Harlem so that's never [__]
good right and I had to fight I got in
Fight by accident right I was just
walking down the street minding my
business playing Angry Birds like a
[__] gangster like ah and some dude
like kind of hit my shoulder oh God and
he freaked out at me he was like oh [__]
you trying to
fight oh you trying to fight oh [__] I'm
from holl [__] I'm from Brooklyn
[__] I'm from St up New York
[__] nothing B what the [__]
happened here a y pause it pause it
please pause it if we can pause it yo
this is the this is so bad I I would
have I I wouldn't have been able to keep
that much energy so Props to you I would
have
bailed at joke
world did it
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out